secretary ellen uh thank you very much
for joining us today it's good to see
you we really uh appreciate you taking
the time
thanks so much thanks for the invitation
uh well also before we start i want to
make sure to thank our audiences on
twitter wsj.com and youtube
um
well madame secretary it's no surprise i
think the first thing i want to ask
about is the state of the u.s economy
right now we've had an enormous amount
of uh
data uh in the in recent days of course
here at our conference we've been
talking about inflation we saw the gdp
contraction in the first quarter but we
also see wages are up housing remains
strong we're getting an enormous amount
of
data painting uh
painting a somewhat confusing picture
what's your best assessment right now
through all of that
of how healthy the economy is
how
one of the biggest risk factors what are
you watching most closely
sure thanks for the question well i i
feel quite good about the strength of
the american economy um the labor market
is really strong
yesterday we got the so-called jolts
data on job openings and turnover and
job openings or at record highs
unemployment is exceptionally low just
during the first quarter of the year
when kovit was uh an issue we still had
1.7 million workers um added to
the paid to payrolls and jobless claims
are at multi-decade lows
so the labor market is very strong
um first quarter gdp was negative
that's gotten some attention but that's
not really a
a good read on the underlying strength
of the economy
the underlying strength of demand is
probably better measured by looking at a
metric called real final sales to
private domestic purchasers that that
takes out inventories government
spending and net
net exports and it gives a very good
read on private sector demand and so
that grew at 3.7
and it means consumer spending and
business investment remain very strong
so it was a peculiar bottom line reading
on gdp
because inventory investment was very
high
but um less than it had been in the
fourth quarter of 2021
when companies were restocking
inventories and net exports are
subtracted from growth that's because
america is outperforming other countries
and you know when you look at metrics
relating to the financial health of
households and businesses
uh that really looks very strong um and
credit quality remains
excellent
banks are well capitalized so i see the
us is very strong now but look inflation
is too high
it's necessary to bring that down
and the global economy is buffeted by
risks uh energy prices are up oil prices
food prices are up the uh russia's
unjustified unprovoked war on ukraine
is
leading to
an escalation of commodity prices
that
can have a tool
globally
the imf
recently lowered their outlook for
global growth
concerned about emerging markets
where debt is already too high where
in many countries there are food
shortages even before the russian war on
ukraine
uh
europe we could see slower growth a
downturn and some of that could spill
over
to us and of course we're on a path
where the fed will be addressing rising
inflation
so i do believe we're going to see solid
growth in the coming year with inflation
coming down but uh there are clearly
risks to the outlook
um so that's a great survey i want to
unpack uh some of those components uh in
turn
stay on inflation for a minute as you
mentioned the fed is meeting today
uh the expectation is that they're going
to raise rates half a percentage point i
know you're not going to comment
directly on on your successor of the fed
but realistically having lived through
inflation knowing what it's like and
this is this inflation has certainly
lasted longer already than the
administration expected and it is taking
a toll on on on households on it's it's
eating up people's wage increases
how far do you think they're going to
need to go roughly
for and for how long to really contain
this inflation bound how bad does it
have to get so you're you're right that
i'm not going to comment on fed policy i
think no one
respects the independence of the fed um
more than i do
uh it is the fed's
uh key job to make sure that inflation
remains low and stable over the medium
term i know that the fed is committed to
doing that there's also an employment
mandate so i'm certain that the fed will
try to use its deploy its tools to
achieve
a soft landing where the economy can
continue to grow we avoid a recession
but inflation comes down i've said
before that the fed will need to be
skillful and also lucky to achieve that
but i believe it's a combination that is
possible in part because
although inflation has been very high
and that's taken a real toll on
households and
really needs to end
um
you know it's not deeply ingrained into
the u.s economy
and i don't think it's influenced
medium-term inflation expectations
significantly and in that way it this is
a different situation
than um paul volcker faced um during his
term as chair
so i i think a soft landing is possible
um
clearly there are dangers in there the
outlook is uncertain but i do believe
that's possible
um i'm going to get to a couple other
things but one one specific thing i do
want to ask you on inflation in this
regard i mean
one of the as you know
um
uh
one of the criticisms for the
administration and for the fed really
had been underestimating the toll of
inflation a year ago one of the
criticisms made of the administration
and and really it goes back to the prior
administration as well as government
stimulus
spending uh related to covet and the
bill that the administration passed over
the last year helped feed this
you're an economist you uh you
understand the the causes of
these phenomena what's your take on
how responsible government spending was
in helping contribute to the problem
that we're facing now on this front
so look inflation is a matter of demand
and supply and the spending that was
undertaken
in the american rescue plan
did
feed demand
but
um
i i do think it was justified and
appropriate at the time
given the risks that the economy faced
at the time that
president biden
was inaugurated we had an economy where
forecasters were envisioning very high
unemployment for a very long time
we we had
especially low-wage workers who had been
laid off
in massive numbers
we saw
cars
lined up
for miles at food banks americans um
worried about not being able to feed
their families get enough to eat and
forecasts were really quite dire
and um
that was one of the biggest risks we
faced that we wanted to address
and really you know the memories of
the recovery following the 2008
um financial crisis were very much alive
in policy makers minds where it really
took a decade to recover um
for the great recession to really um
fully end in the sense that full
employment was regained and during that
period long period of recovery there was
a lot of scarring a lot of americans
dropped out of the labor market um
didn't get jobs were unemployed for a
long time
and really never regained uh employment
and the desire was to avoid that so when
you look at the labor market now and you
see the state that it's in
um
this is really a measure of huge success
um i you know the inflation that we're
experiencing now is perhaps slightly
driven by a labor market that is almost
historically tight but on top of that we
have a lot of pandemic related supply
shocks
energy and price increases supply chain
problems that i think are directly
related to the pandemic and that's why
you're seeing
inflation globally in almost all
advanced economies where there was less
stimulus
so
um look i i think
when you think about the dogs that
aren't barking
we're not we households are in good
financial
shape
we avoided a lot of scarring the labor
market is very strong these are
successes from the policy
the policies that were put in place
problems that we might well have had and
don't have because of the policies that
were undertaken
but
it is important to get inflation down um
to low and stable levels and that's the
fed's job mainly to accomplish although
uh for its part the white house the
biden administration is doing what it
can to also address for example high
energy prices by
releases from the strategic petroleum
reserve
doing what we can to make sure that we
relieve congestion at the ports but look
you know now you're seeing covered
lockdowns in china and um you know these
are factors really outside our control
that unfortunately threaten
to prolong supply chain disruptions that
um will affect our economy with
spillovers too
we've mentioned energy a couple times
and let's just talk there um uh
energy was already uh challenging and as
you noted since the war in uh between
russia and ukraine
uh the energy shock has only grown so
it takes a long time normally to to to
work through
supply issues when it comes to energy so
as you look out in the forecast how long
are we facing do you think roughly uh a
certain kind of energy crunch supply
crunch here it seems like that's
something liable to be with us here for
a while
well
i i agree
i mean
a reason why the president committed to
release a million barrels a day
from the strategic petroleum reserve was
to give american producers
time to ramp up production
but you know unfortunately i think most
producers of oil from shale
they experienced during the pandemic
very low prices and expected the
recovery to take a long time
and they actually cut production rather
than
ramping it up and so um it really is
necessary to see supplies increase um in
the meantime we we have um the releases
from the strategic petroleum reserve
that have helped um you know there's
also a very strong desire around the
world
to
make sure that um russia
is not able to
use
proceeds from its sales of oil
in the global markets to finance the war
and so
very naturally
europe the united states has now banned
imports of russian oil um we've had an
announcement this morning from president
fonder lion that uh the european union
is looking at
cutting off russian oil imports over a
span of the rest of this year
um we need to see the conditions um
exactly how this is going to be
accomplished because it could lead to
higher higher global oil prices as well
but the desire to
to respond to russia's unprovoked attack
on ukraine and to bring the war to an
end is very understandable and important
yeah i was going to ask if uh
morally ethically
the eu action
uh
it obviously comes to that place
economically is it wise is it worrisome
to you
um so you know i'm not sure that i
really understand the details of how
this is going to be accomplished um i
think it's very important that europe is
going to
rid itself of um
dependence that it has on russia as a
source of
supply and we we clearly want to work
with europe to make sure that they have
the energy supplies that are needed um i
think we need to do what we can over the
next year to make sure that we limit the
revenue that russia is able to
get
from selling oil in global markets and
also do what we can to make sure that
we don't see
a large escalation in global oil prices
um a couple of other aspects
of the economy right now you mentioned
the the signs of slowdown in china and
europe
now you're known i think is a bit of a
dollar hawk
the dollar has
grown quite a bit this year it surged
quite quickly are you concerned
that the dollar is getting too strong
and what could we do if so to mitigate
that
look i believe in a
market-based value for the dollar
when
countries are taking actions
designed to purposely
push their currencies down to gain an
unfair trade advantage vis-a-vis the
united states
the united states is prepared to respond
strongly to
um
purposeful um attempts to
uh of other countries to devalue their
currencies but believe in a market-based
value for the dollar
you know clearly u.s interest rates are
rising have risen relative to those in
the le in the rest of the world and so
one of the factors that's
at work i think pushing up the dollar is
um a redirection of
um investments toward
higher yielding
uh returns in the united states and the
in a way that's part of how a tighter
monetary policy works
i want to ask you two other kind of
broader questions about the economy
right now
one is moments like this when things are
shifting quickly when markets are in
some flux as ours have been and coming
down
it's moments like this where you
sometimes tend to see problems come out
uh you know you were you were actually
an economist who early uh nearly 20
years ago uh was warning about the
subprime mortgage problem before that
manifested
at that time so
as you look across the economy and think
where could potential problems lie where
could
things be lurking that that we haven't
seen below the surface are there
particular
areas of concern or interest that you're
looking at closely
uh so
banks are
quite strong i think that the
um reforms that were put in place
uh by dodd-frank after the financial
crisis have led to
more capital
more liquidity and better risk
management
at in the core of our banking system
banks who've endured a lot of stress and
have been able to meet the credit needs
of the economy that's sometimes a sector
where we have concerns
um
we
did see
when the pandemic struck stresses
if it showed up in
in non-bank
the non-bank financial sector in money
market funds
open end
mutual funds often bond funds
perhaps in the hedge fund space
and certainly stresses in markets that
cause the fed to
intervene to stabilize things in a
really almost unprecedented
fashion and um the financial stability
oversight council working with the sec
we're working to address weaknesses in
those sectors to make it less crisis
prone
so
i i feel good about
the strength the overall strength of the
financial sector and its resilience
asset valuations
uh the fed is noted in its recent
reports in in the f-soc uh annual report
we noted that asset valuations are high
in housing obviously there's been a huge
increase in housing prices
ratio of price to rental rates is high
price equity ratios in uh the stock
market are high
but um i don't think we have the same
dangers that um we had in the run-up to
the 2008
uh financial crisis for example in the
housing market credit quality is
excellent we don't have the kind of
mortgage practices that we saw in the
run-up to that crisis but the outlook is
very uncertain the dangers at the global
level are high
i do worry about commodity prices um i
am worried about spillovers from russia
and ukraine that can have adverse
impacts not just on the u.s that is
strongly positioned but
on europe on emerging markets
that you know
could have spillovers to the united
states that's that's where my concerns
are centered
um your you
labor labor economics i think is your is
your specialty as an academic one of the
things we've talked a lot about at our
event
uh in the last 24 hours is how
volatile the workplace is uh how many
times will people be back two days will
they ever be back five days
how many people will go remote how many
people will
move away and never go back to a
headquarters what will happen with
office space
it's it's obviously an incredibly
dramatic and uncertain time
right now
and up for reinvention so when you think
about those aspects of the labor market
and the health of the economy
what are you seeing what are you
watching
to try to understand
changes in behavior
and think about what might be temporary
what might be permanent
and to understand what's going on
well i i agree with you i think that the
pandemic really provoked very
significant structural
changes in the workplace and some of
that is going to prove to be
permanent
um
you know some of this i think is really
healthy
um innovation in how we work how we
interact um
the fact that we can be doing what we're
now doing over
uh zoom
uh
really cheap really changes the way
people live and work and i do think
that's a healthy development
clearly people are changing jobs they
we saw
massive amounts of job shifting across
sectors um
during you know during the pandemic and
in its aftermath and
so there's a lot of structural change
taking place
overall in the labor market what i see
is a very healthy
labor market where people especially at
the lower end in lower wage jobs are
seeing very significant increases in
their wages which is
been a long time coming and uh people
are moving to opportunities into kinds
of work um quitting is it um record
highs that were ever seen in the
statistics and um part of that is a good
healthy
reallocation of people um across jobs
and sectors where uh there are better
matches and they can achieve their
potential
um i'm going to go to the audience in a
minute i know uh there are people with
questions i had a list of policy things
i wanted to get to but i'm going to ask
you one of those which is
um one of your big initiatives has been
the global minimum tax it was going to
be part of
buildback batter legislation which
now seems uh well not very likely i
guess is a fair way to put it in poland
it's uh its face resistance is the
global minimum tax going to
make it or is it is it not going to to
ever get to be enacted
well i very much hope that it will be
enacted
i
feel it's an incredibly important global
initiative that is in the interests of
the united states and
countries throughout the world and what
we've seen over decades is a race to the
bottom in terms of corporate tax rates
one country
lowering tax rates to attract businesses
and others
responding and i think putting an end to
that unhealthy
competition
so that
all countries have some ability to raise
revenues
create create a level playing field for
businesses globally
um but raise the revenue that we need to
invest in our economy in infrastructure
and investment in people
to make our economy productive this is a
very healthy shift i think if any
reconciliation package is passed in the
coming months
certainly democrats
i believe unanimously favorite uh the
provisions that would be necessary in
the united states for us to be in
compliance with the global minimum tax
they were included in the house passed
package
so
if any reconciliation package is passed
i expect us to come into compliance
i think the eu is very close to adopting
the global minimum tax uh you mentioned
poland a poland was a holdout i think
poland has some issues with the eu
frankly i don't think that they largely
pertain to the global minimum tax itself
but rather other issues um between
poland and the eu so
um i i really expect the eu to
um pass this into law uh this spring and
i think that would be a good example to
the united states to show a very
significant um piece of the economic
activity uh in the world has come into
compliance and it sets a good example
for us
so you have real hopes it sounds like
that reconciliation is going to
maybe get this done if nothing else
comes along so it's very much alive for
you it sounds like
yes i mean i don't know what will happen
with reconciliation but um i remain
hopeful that some
reconciliation a package will be passed
and i believe that this will be a
component
on the revenue raising side if any
package becomes law and you know i i
think this is an important initiative
and i would love to see bipartisan
support for it i think it's broadly in
the interest of the united states and
not partisan
do we have questions out here anybody if
we could throw up the lights for a
second anybody have any questions for uh
secretary ellen
uh
james
can i ask about the
future for the dollar and um in
particular whether you're
whether you see any limit to how much
the
treasury you oversee
can take advantage of having the global
reserve currency
um to enforce foreign policy sanctions
um most recently uh confiscating
russia's reserves obviously is the the
key for the question here is there some
limit you you can't go beyond before
countries stop using
the dollar as a safe store of value
particularly countries that worry they
might fall on the wrong side of america
at some point
well
i mean certainly the fact that the
dollar is used so widely as a reserve
currency
does mean that the u.s has the ability
to impose sanctions
that can take a severe toll
that ability needs to be used sparingly
wisely
and
when it comes to sanctions as severe as
those we've imposed on russia
the hurdle i think for imposing such
sanctions needs to be high
um
you know it
we have only rarely i believe in the
case of iran and north korea um impose
sanctions on a country's central bank
and the decision to do that to russia is
not one that was undertaken lightly
i would point out that
there it involved a very broad coalition
of countries that felt that it was
warranted that is a rare situation to
prevail
but we had the entire g7 and other
countries even including switzerland
that felt that this was an appropriate
sanction
so the bar is not low
and i think it should be it should be
high
but i think we value we value very much
and gain from having the dollar used as
a reserve currency
there are very good fundamental reasons
based on the strength of the us economy
the stability of
and
of economic management the liquidity of
our markets the safety of the dollar our
rule rule of law and institutions
that make the dollar
a
an important reserve currency i don't
see any other currency at this point
that could begin to rival that
and madam secretary i know we're short
but i'm going to take prerogative this
is the last question i promise and thank
you again for your time but since sure
hadn't really gotten to russia and
you've been running you've been the
point person for russia sanctions let me
ask you two russia related questions to
end
one is we've imposed various rounds of
sanctions
on russia how much more potentially
could there be and and how much more
even beyond what it is severe could it
get
and and by the same token
when you think ahead to a time beyond
the war are you yet thinking in any way
about
whether and how
it might even be possible to
reforge some economic ties
with russia down the road or are we on a
path to where
even after the war russia is going to be
isolated for for the foreseeable future
how are you thinking about that
well let me just say
we're we're certainly are looking at
further measures that we can take
um to respond to russia's aggression
against ukraine and we're in constant
discussions with our partners about uh
further sanctioned packages i don't want
to preview specifics but um there are
certainly additional actions that we can
take and probably would take if if
russia continues this war against
ukraine
um
although i do believe our sanctions have
been quite effective
and
have really made a huge difference
to the economic outlook both long-term
and short-term in russia inflation is
very high the russian economy is clearly
going into recession the russians have
admitted that and it's taken an enormous
toll in terms of foreign investment and
access to goods that russia needs
to compete uh over the long term i think
it's really damaged
russia but yes there's a path to
de-escalation of sanctions and um if
you know if there's a truce that's
risked or a peace agreement um it would
be certainly appropriate to
consider a path to de-escalation and i
don't have anything specific to give you
on that but certainly that needs and is
part of the thinking
okay well treasury secretary jenny
yellen thank you very much for taking
this time with us today at such an
eventful moment we really appreciate uh
your time so thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]